hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to
today's live broadcast nucleic acid
purification
understand the details and tackle the
routines
our webinar will be presented to you by
dr tim shumark
global marketing manager automation and
pcr at eppendorf
dr andreas von bohl head of the
bioanalysis
automation group and dr milan dearest
product manager bioanalysis department
both of macareen nagel i'm christy
jewell of labrutz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored by eppendor
in cooperation with macarene nagel for
more information
on our sponsors please click on the
sponsor's logos
at the left side of your screen now
before we begin i would like to
encourage you
to get the most out of today's webinar
by submitting as many questions as you
want
at any time you want during the
presentation simply type them into the
ask a question box on the left
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on that support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or use that ask a question box on your
left
today's presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
following this presentation those
credits can be obtained
by clicking on the tab at the top right
and following the process to obtain your
credit
before i pass on the presentation to our
speakers i would like to point out that
you can read full biographies
on dr tim shaw mark dr andreas bumble
and dr milan dearest in the biography
tab
at the top of the screen gentlemen the
stage is yours
thank you christy for this nice
introduction uh this is milan dearest
from macquarie nagle here speaking
actually we've been wanting to do this
seminar together with
eppendorf for quite some time now and
the current situation was
kind of the reason why we decided we
really need to do this
now because basically at this point we
get so many inquiries regarding
automated nucleic acid purification
um that we really struggle to to answer
all these inquiries and to
try to to get to every customer so
basically at this point
this webinar addresses two kinds of
people
on the one hand of course labs that are
right now
in need for automated nucleic acid
purification
most of them in the current situation of
course
maybe related to cobit 19 workflows
and second of all we must not forget
that
many people research scientists lab
technicians
students and so on are forced to stay at
home
i mean they might not be able to perform
experiments in the lab
but they might be at home
and want to use this time to plan new
experiments and workflows
so they might be thinking about uh
automated nucleic acid purification as
well
so this webinar basically aims to give
all of these people some background
information and technical guidance
when planning or considering on
automated experiments
so let's look at the agenda for today's
webinar
i am going to start uh with giving you
some
background information uh coming first
of all from the
application sites or regarding um
or when you have a certain application
in mind or a certain experiment planned
you should there are some basic
questions that you
should ask yourself before starting on
the experiment of course
then i'm going to talk about the
principles of nucleic acid purification
we're going to look at
like the technological background for
commercial purification kits magnetic
beads versus silicon membrane kits these
are the most prominent ones in the
market
uh we're going to show you the
advantages of
automated nuclear gas purification this
is something that is then presented by
tim
from eppendorf and he's also going to
introduce you to the
ap motion platforms and then from
our r d side with a lot of hands-on
experience
andreas is going to present some example
projects and applications
as well as tips and tricks for obtaining
optimal results
so for the first part i'm going to start
with these basics and as i said in this
part we are looking at a couple
of important questions that you should
have an answer to
before starting a purification workflow
before establishing a purification
workflow
in general regardless of whether it is
an automated workflow or if it's a
manual workflow
there are a couple of questions that you
should have answered before starting
these workflows
and number one is you should always look
at the kind of sample that you're
purifying from
so it actually makes a huge difference
for the purification workflow
whether you're purifying from cultured
mammalian cells
or from a heart to life tissue whether
it is a bacterial culture
or a complex sample matrix like a swab
or something like this
so always keep in mind that different
sample materials require different
chemistries regarding lysis and
purification
so if you think about bacteria for
example there are also of course
differences within bacteria
there are bacteria that are relatively
easy to
crack open uh gram gram negative
bacteria like e coli
are usually no problem but there are
also some nasty hard to like bacteria
like cephalococcus or something like
this so
where we really have to assist uh the
lysis either
enzymatically or mechanically so always
be aware of the kind of sample material
that you're purifying from then
second of all uh you should always keep
in mind or
always consider what kind of nucleic
acid are you looking for
uh is it genomic dna is it rna is it
plasmid dna
genomic dna most often is of least
concern
because if you have a large enough
sample
available it's usually no problem to
to release the dna and unpurify it rna
on the other hand is a little bit more
delicate there's also a lot of rna in a
cell
a lot of different types of rna most
people will be
looking at messenger rna to quantify
gene expression levels but rna
is very susceptible to towards
degradation so
uh in in ambient temperature or in
in an unprotected environment it will
rapidly degrade and
degraded rna will then lead to a false
qpcr signal so it will
have a huge impact on the results that
you obtain so most rna purification kits
actually have specially designed buffers
that make sure that the rna stays
intact so that's important to keep in
mind and when we look for example at
plasma dna uh you should always keep in
mind that
of course plasma dna is derived from
bacteria usually
bacteria don't only have plasma dna they
also have genomic dna
and the reason or or the um the methods
to separate those is the
is the lysis basically so plasma dna
kits usually use an alkaline lysis which
just
perforates the membrane enough to
release the
uh the plasmid content of the cell and
the genomic dna
stays inside the cell remnants and can
be sedimented or
or pelleted by centrifugation so
each and every kit has special uh
special buffers special chemistries to
um
fit your purification or to to
fit your purification workflow and last
of all
um you should always of course also
design your experiment according to the
application
that you are using so what do you need
the nucleic acids for is it pcr
or tpcr a special sequencing workflow or
cloning plasmids are also often used for
transactions of sensitive cell lines so
you want basically an endotoxin-free
plasmid or even used for gene therapy
and each and every application has its
requirements regarding
dna rna purity concentration
quantity and integrity
so taken together when you take
all these parameters i mentioned into
account
the sample the target molecule the
application
and you're also clear about the
requirements regarding like purity
concentration and and quantity of
nucleic acid required
then you will be able to identify a
suitable
method or kit for nucleic acid
purification
and that actually brings me
to the to the next chapter uh which
aims to explain to you the the
principles of nucleic acid purification
because
when i think back to my time in the lab
as a student maybe
i wasn't really thinking about uh what
step in the purification proto protocol
does what
what is this buffer used for what is the
purpose of this buffer why is it
composed like this
um it is important to have this
background knowledge because
you can you will often run into problems
regarding your sample license regarding
the purity and most of the times if you
think a little bit about
what is the purpose of each and every
step you're able to solve these problems
yourself
and that's often much easier and much
more
much less painful to to think about in
advance so i want to give you this
background knowledge on
the principles of nucleic acid
purification
so if we look a little bit back into
into the history
into the late 1970s uh
people were already using nucleic acids
for
a wide range of applications these
applications might be
simpler or less complex than today's
applications but
but still at that time this was the
state of the art
um so you pcr was not a thing yet was
not invented until the early 80s
sanger sequencing was not commercially
available yet so all of these things
were not there yet in the lab so what
people
did is um analyzing fragments of dna
that they um that they ran on an agarose
gel like we still do it with
pcr fragments today after we did a pcr
and then of course they compared these
gel band patterns and they wanted to
further analyze
single bands out of these gels so they
were looking
for a technique to have
cut out gel pieces and then re-purify
the rna or dna
in that case re-purify the dna from the
gel piece
so that's what fogelstein and his
co-workers did in that paper
so they tested a lot of different
buffers
that were able to dissolve gel pieces
and with one buffer composition
namely a buffer that contained k-frophic
salt in high concentrations they were
indeed able to dissolve the gel and
when they tried to precipitate the dna
again in the solution
uh the dna seemed to have vanished so it
was not
there was no palette of dna it was not
in the solution
it could not have vanished through the
air so where was the dna
and they found that the dna was actually
bound to the glass
and this was basically they didn't know
about the
their success at that time of course but
this was the discovery
of silica as a component to isolate or
purify
nucleic acids and today i would say
or in the past 20 years silica membrane
purification kits
were very very successful and made up
most of the kids that were used in the
market i think
although we have other kids now um
coming up again
but these silica membrane kits they were
basically a revolution in the
purification of nucleic acids so
how do they work on um
on on a chemical level so
um so everybody knows these uh mini prep
columns like
they are depicted here on the left side
these are basically
columns that have a little membrane
inside
where you basically run your buffers
containing the dna through and these
membranes are basically made out of
sheets of silica
and when you look at the the chemistry
behind this
basically you have a solution a
buffer based on water a solution that
contains the dna
and when you add k-tropic salt to that
buffer
uh the dna is stripped of its hydride
shell
and you enable a hydrogen bond between
the dna
and the silica membrane and this is how
you can bind the dna to the column
then you wash the dna and then
in the end you can elude the dna and
this is basically how every
silica membrane-based nucleic acid
purification kit works
so if we look at the uh
procedure of such a nucleic acid
purification kit it's
more or less always the same
you start off with elisis
which usually includes of course your
sample
a lysis buffer and sometimes also
enzymes like protein ace k
um to yeah to dissolve your sample
in the lysis buffer then you usually add
another buffer
the binding buffer which adjusts the
conditions in a way that enables
binding of nucleic acids to the silicon
membrane then you
run this solution through your spin
column
by centrifuging it and the dna is bound
to the silica membrane
and then you have usually one two or
three washing steps depending on the
type of sample depending on the purity
you need
and in the end you elude your dna from
the column with a
tris buffered solution or water
and then you can use your dna for
whatever downstream application
you have whether it is cloning a pcr or
an ngs library prep for example
today we have these silica columns in
lots of different
shapes and formats the most popular one
is of course the mini prep i think
everybody has done
a plasmid mini prep or a jello pcr
purification
mini prep in his life
today but there are of course other
formats going on from midi
over maxi preps which where you can
really put a large amounts of cells or
tissues as input material
and of course when it comes to
automation because this is also a
webinar
that is aimed for automate people
interested in automation we have these
high throughput formats
where you can purify from 8 or even 96
samples at the same time
and what came up in the past years and
which
is yeah getting more and more popular
are magnetic beads so although of course
they don't use
silica um they are based on a very
similar principle which is binding of
nucleic acids to the beads in presence
of a k-tropic salt
so the the magnetic beads have an iron
core which is coated
in that case with a carboxy group
and in the presence of catropic salt we
have like a
very similar mechanism to the silica
membrane
uh the k-tropic salt strips the dna of
its hydrate shell and enables
a hydrogen bond between the dna molecule
and the
coated magnetic particle and the
purification workflow
is from a chemical perspective very
similar
but from a practical perspective it's
quite different because you don't
process a magnetic base kit in a
centrifuge or you don't process it with
with vacuum but as the name suggests
you you perform a magnetic separation so
you have a lysate
or a lysate where you add
magnetic piece and binding buffer and
then
the uh the binding of dna to the beast
is enabled and then you
do a magnetic separation by holding your
vessel against the magnet
so the magnetic particles are collected
at one end of the tube and then you can
switch the buffer solutions
and in the end elude your dna
from the magnetic beads and this is
basically yeah how these kits work
i explained to you like how a silicon
membrane kit works how
a magnetic beat based kit works and
since this is a webinar
targeted also for customers or or lab
technicians and scientists interested in
automation
uh we're like um
displaying the pros and cons of these
different technologies
here and later on especially
in the last part we will see from a
practical perspective
like what are the advantages and
disadvantages of
silica versus magnetic bead kits
in different applications and now i
think i will hand over to
um to tim who is going to jump a little
bit into
the automation or the process of
automation um
in nucleic acid purification and
yeah okay
yeah thank you thank you milan uh for
this fantastic presentation
i'm going to take over from from here
and in the next
yeah 15 minutes or so i'm i'm going to
give you a little insight
on how to automate nucleic acid
purification so basically
how to get those principles that milan
described previously
into an automation background
but before we get to the dirty details i
would like to
take you a step back and basically
discuss
why are you automating a workflow
anyhow so what are the advantages
of of automation and
for my motivation i have to say that i
took inspiration
from a presentation given by bob ganzer
from
beam therapeutics so bob if you are here
in this presentation um thank you for
this
uh cool inspiration that you've given me
so
um uh
if we look at different industries and
how they evolved
so if you look at those at those
pictures um
on top you can see a picture of a car
factory
in the early 1900s and
at the bottom you can see a biological
laboratory in the early 1900s and in
fact the
laboratory at the bottom this is the lab
of a very famous person so this is
alexander fleming
so and over the time the way that people
work and the way that industries
work have changed quite a bit so if
we look at a modern car factory and a
modern lab to our rights
we we can see some drastic changes so
what you can see is that in in a modern
car factory
a lot of the processes they have been
automated they have been taken over
by robots whereas if you look at the
bottom and if you take
a closer look at the at the laboratory
now nowadays
you can see that honestly not so much
has changed in this 120 years
and why is that so the first question is
why did the the car producing industries
jump to automation to automated
processes
um yes of course to produce more cars um
but
um that is most likely not the only
reason
um there are also other things that have
to be considered which is
the standardization of a process and
um to have uh equal quality
of the of the product and
um if if if we take a further look at
at biological research um then there is
a very interesting phenomenon
i think that most of you who are
listening to this course are familiar
with
a thing called moore's law and this
moore's law says that
the calculating a capacity
of computers is basically doubling every
two years
and there is another very interesting
statistic and this is called erom's law
it's moore's law spelled backwards and
it says that
the development of drugs
is getting more and more expensive over
the years so you can see here in this
diagram that the cost
for producing a single drug is
uh is is rising so basically the the
amount of drugs that you are
you're getting for a certain amount of
money is getting lower and lower
and and this means uh in in order to be
productive and in order to be successful
also in research is
that um you you somehow have to increase
productivity
and that can obviously be done by
technologies it it can be done by
a smart approach sure but
i know that most of you have experienced
that in the lab that sometimes
it is based on a brute force method
um that that you have to run a lot of
experiments to get things to work
and this is also where automation comes
into play because this is
where uh most of people are start to
think about automation because
if you want to automate a process um you
want to get the following done you want
to increase your throughput
so instead of testing eight samples
instead of doing eight experiments you
want to do 80 experiments or
something like that so but
the the throughput alone is not
the the only driver and the most
important driver
at least not from my perspective to
automate a process
and now i will i will go back and take a
closer look at the
actual application that we talk about so
um
looking at engine at a genomics workflow
where the nucleic acid extraction or
nucleic acid purification
um is a uh is a staple and it's a core
method um it is also important to
understand that
this is not a method that is sitting
there in a in a vacuum
so it is part of a larger workflow it is
part of a
of a research question because i think
no one is doing nucleic acid extractions
for fun um just because it's so great
um to to run uh uh purification after
purification of the purification
so if you look at this at this workflow
here at the beginning there is a primary
sample
where you extract your nucleic acids and
then you have um some sort of downstream
processing or some sort of downstream
analysis which can be next generation
sequencing
it can also be a a traditional pcr
or a real time or qpcr can be different
things
so and if we look at the workload um
if we look at the time that you spend to
do certain tasks and
here highlighting the nucleic acid
extraction is that
a regular nucleic acid acid extraction
looking at 96 samples will involve
roughly 500 pipetting steps it's 500
pipetting steps
where each and every step you can do a
mistake and the hands on time is about
roughly two hours it depends a bit on
the technology
it depends a bit on your equipment but
if you do it manually
um that's a good estimate and
if we if we look at the times for for
some of the other things here
you can see that the number of pivoting
steps and also the hands on time
it can reach very high levels
with up more than thousand pipetting
steps and several hours of hands on time
so what's that what does it tell us
there are certain tasks in the lab
which are very tedious it means it's a
repetitive task that you have to do over
and over again
and by repeating this task over and over
again
it gets tiring uh there is a lot of
pipetting steps involved
so it becomes more and more error prone
and um and by that um it means that
uh the um the the chance of failure
getting higher and higher so it is
likely that
there will be a drop out of either
single samples or in the worst case even
of a full essay or experiment if you do
everything manually
so if we look at the at the consequences
is that
um the if if you have to do a tedious
and repetitive tasks is that
um your concentration goes down um which
obviously increases the risk of errors i
think everybody knows the situation
where you're pipetting in the lab 96
well played
somebody steps in asks you a question
you're looking back at your plate you
have no idea where you stop pipetting
so and of course this also increases the
number of failed experiments
another thing is a thing that is
dedicated related to to working in the
lab manually
with your body itself so the
rsi is a situation
where you get problems with your uh with
your arm your hand and your elbow
that means you basically get uh gets
from your work
which can increase your
the dropout rate so that you have to
take a sick leave you have to stay at
home and you might even get
um severe long-term problems for that
and of course and that i think it's what
most of you are experiencing
is that those repetitive tedious tasks
they take away time for more
intellectual tasks like data analysis or
setting up
new experiments thinking about the
results from the last experiment
and it is not very satisfying to do that
every day
i understand that from time to time it
can be
a meditative process um to do
extractions and maybe also do a large
number but on the long run
you won't be very satisfied if you only
have to do that
so in sum it means that
if you drop out if experiments are if
experiments are failing
and the cost increases and the
productivity
gets lower and lower and this is
especially problematic in the sense that
more effort needs to be put in um to
make discoveries
all right and besides that increase in
productivity that you get
from um from automation and and
throughput there are some general
automation benefits
um one obviously reproducible
reproducibility and standardization it
means no matter if you
if you run your um pipetting robot your
automated system
today or tomorrow in the morning or in
the evening
the the performance will always be the
same
a robot does not have a bad day
and you can compare results over several
operators
over several days you have
sometimes not always increased accuracy
and precision
there is a misconception that a robot
will always perform better as a human
which i personally think is not true if
you are
a experienced lab technician or person
working very long in the lab
you will be very accurate and precise
maybe even more than
a pipetting robot the question is
will you be as accurate and precise at
the 70s well of a 96 well as well as at
the first well
so this is where robots shine especially
in those days of course
personal and sample safety is a concern
so if you can give a task to a pipetting
robot that can
increase your personal safety but it can
also protect your samples from potential
contamination
and another important thing is the
is the documentation and data integrity
so the picture i took here is actually
the lab notebook from
from graham bell i have to admit that my
own lab notebook when i was working in
the lab was not looking
that different not saying that i am as
smart as graham bell just saying that
there is not much that has changed
within these
more than 100 years there is a big
change if you switch to an automated
workflow because
uh you you can stop um
writing up everything manually by hand
because the robot is keeping track of
your samples so sample tracking
sample tracing reagent
tracking and stuff like that is much
easier if you work within
a automated scenario
so but now what is actually needed
if you want to um automate your nucleic
acid purification
well you need some sort of tool which is
handling your liquids
so you need some sort of dispensing
tools um ideally
covering a volume range which is
suitable
for nucleic acid purification
so that is depending on the scale you're
you're purifying
but something between
50 microliter up to 1000
microliter and that is i think it's a
is a good range it can be higher um
the the volume range that you need if
you're looking at bigger preparations
but i think that is a that is a good uh
starting point
what you also need uh on your liquid
handler
is some sort of gripping or transporting
device
because no matter if you're doing
magnetic beat based extraction
or if you're doing a silica based
extraction
you will have to transport either plates
um to a magnet and back to the magnet or
you have to
position stuff on onto a vacuum unit
or something similar so this is the
thing that you need
no matter if you're looking into
automating your silica based workflows
or
your magnetic feed-based workflows so
if we now take a closer look and in what
is needed
for the two different scenarios that
milan introduced
so if you are automating
a magnetic beat based workflow
uh you obviously need a magnet
ideally this magnet would have a
so-called
unz slas format so a standard plate
format because then
can be easily placed on an automatic
liquid handler
i'm personally for nucleic acid
purification i'm
a friend of rod magnets as they are
shown there
because if working with deep well plates
they will give you a good performance
and what you need in addition is some
sort and that has been depicted on top
some sort of mixing module because
in between the purification step you
want to
mix your your dna and beat solution
uh in in order to get a
homogeneous solution to get your
the best the best possible
extraction results so if if we take a
look at a
a silica based approach you
would need some sort of
strategy to work with those filter
plates
the most common system in the automated
world
is a so-called vacuum module
so what has happened there is that you
put your
filter plate with some sort of lid
and then by pressure
under pressure basically the liquid has
been sucked through this filter plate
it's been then refilled for example with
washing buffer
or illusion buffer and
depending on the collection vessel you
can either collect the waste or the
final
elude of this workflow
so if we talk about actual systems so
from
an eppendorf perspective and i will not
go into
into much details here is um that we
have
two very good options uh basically three
very good options for automating your
nucleic acid
purification workflow one is um on the
low to medium throughput and it's the
so-called ep motion
5073. this is well suited
for a magnetic beat based kits
and then we have a solution on the
on the higher throughput range so medium
to high throughput range
which is the ep motion 5075 you can see
on the right hand side we there have one
model which is capable of
operating with the vacuum chamber so it
has a built-in vacuum chamber so
you can work with silica based kits
and we have one version which has a
built-in
mixer and shaker and this is the so
called t
version and this can deal with magnetic
beat-based kits
um one word for throughput so we were
now phrasing that low to high
throughput of course um the the
perception of what is the low and
and high throughput um this this can
differ very much
so usually it's the best to to talk
about um sample numbers maybe sample
numbers
per hour or per day because that helps
in the discussion either with
with uh with uh mike reinagel also with
eppendorf to estimate
what would be the best system for you
but now take
let's take a look at a um at an actual
example
of how an automated
process can look like and i also made
that very brief because i don't want to
deep dive into the software
we choose the nucleoma pathogen kit
which can extract
viral dna and and rna
and i think you're with me that
especially in those times this is a kit
which is of
of high interest so what you can see on
the left hand side
is the so-called protocol at a glance so
it's the first
part of the of the protocol where it
describes you what you would do manually
and
i think that is some sort of script that
most of you in the lab are following
so if you want to automate that um the
the first
part of this process would be off deck
so it would still be done manually as um
this needs
to be done under a biosafety cabinet
of course the the lysis
can be the most tricky step in
automating such a workflow
because depending on your material
you can either automate it or it might
be better to do that
manually and this can be defined by
several factors it can be defined
by by the kit itself but it can it's
mostly defined by the starting material
so there is
material which can be easily lysed for
example certain bacteria
there is material which is very hard to
life
for example certain plants in this
specific scenario
we are talking about pathogens about
something which is potentially
infectious
so in this case um i would
i would recommend to to do that under a
biosafety cabinet
and then move on to the robot once you
know
everything has been lysed and saved
so for the second part of the protocol
so everything
starting for the binding process
as well as the washing steps which might
be the most tedious ones
uh what we did is um basically uh we
translated
um the steps in this protocol into
program steps on the robot so you can
see it on the right hand side and they
are human readable
so the software that we are using is
very easy it's drag and drop based
you can learn it very quickly um there
are
several options so obviously you can you
can program the app and off robots
yourself
if you're interested it's not incredibly
hard
so it's something that you can that you
can learn quite
quite fast but we also have a lot of
pre-programmed
methods ready we have a vendor and
customer qualified
um
message ready for you so that that you
can use and we also have services
that help you set up the robot and the
protocol itself
so how does how does such a protocol
perform and here are some performance
data
both for this particular kit both for
dna on on top and
the the rna on the bottom
so what has been done there is that
we were using the nucleomark pathogen
kit on an ep motion 5075
with samples that have been spiked
either with
bacteriophage dna or bacteriophage rna
and then we evaluated the outcome
of this of this
purification by a
real-time pcr so it was a reverse
transcriptase real-time pcr for the rna
and as you can see we were using serial
dilutions
and um so with um
diluting our rna you can see that we we
always have and these are the blue bars
that we have a very good
yield and that um the ct very uh the ct
value
respectively the yield is uh linear
uh to the dilution so that that shows
that
the robot is performing very well there
so this is an
example for a fully
or nearly fully automated process the
nucleomark pathogen kit
i also would like to draw your attention
very quickly
to something else which is what we
phrase as partial automation so what you
can see here back to the car industry
is people working with exoskeletons and
it's helping them to do
um the most tedious or the most tiresome
tasks
and this is also something which is
possible so there are very small
automation solutions which can be
either working like a large pipette or
this can be very small robots where you
don't
automate the full process but maybe the
most
tiresome steps or the most complicated
steps uh
a good example um in hindsight of
nucleic acid purification would be
something like
the washing off of the plates adding
washing buffer or also the whole big
cleanup
so
i personally would always consider
automation if the task is
very repetitive and or tedious
if it is very tired if it is very error
prone
if it if it requires a lot of precision
if manual reproducibility is poor
and if samples or operators need to be
protected
and of course if documentation is a
problematic
if you if you automate um documentation
is standardized and processes can be
streamlined and
this is um these are facts which are
true regardless of the throughput so
this is something
which is even helpful if you are just
doing 8 16
24 samples there are small automation
systems out there with
which can fit virtually every lab bench
and this is i think which is very
important so
choose the right system for your task
don't always go for the biggest
available
option look what is really helping you
so you you are smart working in the lab
so
it's good to have a smart automation
at your site helping you to do your
daily work
and with that
i want to hand over to andreas who will
tell us a little bit more on
the automation options on macri nail
kits on the ep motion itself
okay thank you tim for handing over
yeah as tim already mentioned we will
dig a little bit deeper into the
different
options of microenable kits on ep motion
systems
just as milan has already told you in
the beginning there are two main
technologies which can be applied
on ep motion systems from renegade on
the left side we have the magnetic beat
based purification kits
on the right side we have silica
membrane-based purification kits
and these two technologies can be
implemented on
on these platforms just to show you a
brief
overview which kits are already
validated or available as validated
scripts on the ep motion systems on the
left side you can see
a brief depiction about all our nuclear
mag
kits meaning magnetic beat based kits
which have been automated successfully
on the ep motion 5075
you can see it's a very diverse range
from
dna extraction from tissue or plant
samples over rna
extraction dna extraction from food
samples or even
of course nowadays a very hot topic
viral rna isolation from
from clinical samples or from medical
samples
and on the right side we have the silica
membrane-based technologies
available in two different formats of
course on the one hand
the 96 well plates and on the other hand
we offer a smaller more flexible format
which is called the eight-way strips and
as you can see
the different kits which have been
automated range
also about a very diverse set of samples
such as pcr cleanup plasmid purification
but also other dna species
such as cfdna or even at the bottom
recommend protein purification in a 96
volt format
so in total around 90 to 95 percent of
the
mn high throughput kits have been
automated on the ep
motion system so far
of course one of the most frequently
asked questions we get is what is the
advantage or disadvantage about
one technology against each other so
what is the advantage of magnetic beat
based technology against silica
membrane-based technology
especially in terms of automation i mean
i did already a brief
introduction to this in the beginning
and now i want to focus on
two kits which have been automated on
epimotion systems
with different technologies but which
tackle the same application basically
the isolation of viral rna
from medical samples and as you can see
on the left
the main advantage of the magnetic
bead-based purification is the
flexibility
so you can easily adjust your workflow
to sample numbers such as
maybe seven samples in one one or 75
or 48 or 96 so you can
really vary the sample number very
easily from one to one with the silica
membrane-based technology on the right
side
it's more practical to do multiples of
eight because in the end
these kits are processed by a vacuum so
you have to seal
the unused welds otherwise you lose the
vacuum pressure
for the processing so thereby you are
more fixed to a
yeah multiple of 8 sample number or even
always 96 samples
on the other hand the disadvantage of or
slight disadvantage of the magnetic beat
based procedures
are that they always take longer because
you you always need to aspirate and
dispense more buffers in comparison
to the silica membrane base kits you can
see on the left 130 minutes
approximately for 96 samples
with the magnetic peak based
purification kit and on the other hand
only 90 minutes with a vacuum based
silica membrane-based purification kit
the advantage of the silica
membrane-based kit is clearly also the
tip consumption so
the tip consumption is of course lower
in comparison to the magnetic bead base
kit
on the other hand the magnetic bead base
kit has a lower that volume or a lower
illusion volume
so in comparison to the silicon membrane
kit so you can see in the end
it's not that one technology is superior
about the other
it's more what is your key application
and what are you looking for
which you have to consider for your
optimal
choosing and choosing the optimal
technology in the end
just if you're interested in to dig
deeper into specific applications
eppendorf and mn together have recently
published
a series of application notes targeting
distinct applications for example dna
extraction from ffpe samples rna
extraction or on the smaller platform
for the 5073 isolated viral rna dna
isolation from medical samples
dna isolation from tissue samples or dna
deletion from blood samples
so these application nodes are all
available
on the home pages and please of course
feel free
if you have any questions to come
to ask them in the end of the session or
to
contact us separately in the next part i
just wanted to focus briefly
about three exemplary projects and
applications
eppendorf and mm have done together
in the past the first project is a
medical research project
on the 5073 platform so on the smaller
platform for a lower throughput
with 24 samples per run the main
application of this lab was to
to isolate viral and dna and rna
swap samples and then in the next step
subsequently
subject subject them to qpcr or qrt pcr
so basically the the main task the first
step of the workflow was the nucleic
acid purification using a kit of
macronutrient in this case the nuclear
micropathogen kit and then
in the second step also on the same
instrument the qpcr setup was also
set up so this shows that the
instruments
are not only for nuclear asset
purification but they can also use for
other applications showing the
versatility of these methods
of these systems um
the next project i wanted to briefly
describe is also a medical research
project about cancer profiling
the main application was dna extraction
from ffbe samples
those of you know or who are working
with ffbe samples know how tedious
these sample preparation can be
honestly i have to say this was one of
the most complex
nucleic acid purification workflows we
have established
on automation platforms so far
the reason for this is that with fpe
samples you first have to de-paraffinize
the sample then you have to decross link
and then
you can start with the lysis and
subsequently with the nucleic acid
extraction
so you have a lot of pre-treatment steps
which are usually
done manually and our aim was to
automate these these steps as good as we
can and in the end we had a hands-free
departurization and purification
purification workflow with a maximum
degree of automation
with only one manual intervention with
to a very distinct time point so
you can really put the glock on two
hours and you
walk to the system do some manual
pipetting three steps and that's it and
then you press start again so it was
really minimum of hands on time
and in the end what was really nice the
performance was equal to the manual
preparation
so in the end the customer was very
happy
that this tedious work and very time
consuming and also
time consuming and complicated work
could be now automated on the ep motion
systems
and coming to the last project one of my
favorite projects honestly i have to say
i i did with tim together a few years
ago
in the field of applied testings this
was a national institute
national forest institute in europe
and their aim was the investigation of
illegal wood shopping
so basically they were investigating
the um
they were checking the thermal waste as
well as the remains of cutted
trees in national parks and we're
comparing them
by dna sequencing so basically it's a
little bit like forest forensics or tree
forensics
and the main challenge of this was that
of course we had a kit the nuclear spin
96 plant kit for this purpose
but as you can imagine wood or sawmill
waste is not the best sample type to
extract dna out of it so you have a very
hard sample type and you have a very low
amount
of dna so and
additionally this institute also wanted
to check for fighter pathogens
so in the end they had a lot of
different applications and in the end we
had to do
some adaptations on the method on the
system
but now it's running freely so although
if the kit doesn't say this is
specifically for this
sample material or this application
there's always
something that r d can check if we can
make your application happy
happen in the end and with that i wanted
to
come to the next topic which will be a
little bit
tips and tricks for automated nucleic
acid purification so the session before
was more specific to my
negative kids and now it's a more
general
recommendation if you are going for
automation for nuclear acid purification
so we speak tim already spoke a little
bit about it
so what points to consider for
automation of course there are very
a lot of different points one should
consider before automating
um there are the main points from a
technic birth perspective
is always what is your throughput so do
you have a higher throughput a medium or
low throughput
and of course what are your application
requirements maybe you don't only want
to automate
nuclear asset purification but you also
want to automate other workflows maybe
you want to do limiting dilutions or
sample dilutions on the platform
maybe you can do the qpcr setup or ngs
workflows on the platform
so the versatility of of the platform
this is something you should always
consider
if you're going into the automation and
of course the next part
it's always the budget which is one key
factor
if you go going for automation and then
in the other part is the technology so
do you want to use magnetic beats do you
want to use silica membrane
so and of course does the performance
meet in the end with your expectations
another point which i highlighted here
is the service and support point
which you should consider already in the
beginning and this is not
meaning the service and support from
from like eppendorf or mahoney
it's more into who is using in the end
uh the platform so especially in
universities you buy a platform maybe
the phd student leaves after three years
because he has finished
so how how can the next person easily
work with these platforms so the ease of
use for
platforms for automation platforms such
as the promotion system
is of course a big key factor one should
consider
so now i have two examples of the most
common troubleshootings we see from the
r d side or from the application side
quite often in nuclear ethic
purification kits
so the one first example is the
inhibition of downstream analytics due
to wash buffer carryover
so basically the symptom is a qpcr or
pcr inhibition
and the reason for that is in 90 of the
cases that you have a
carryover of the wash buffer of ethanol
into the elevate and the end
and this ethanol inhibits then the
downstream analytics
so the symptom is always qpcr inhibition
and you can diagnose it very easily if
you check the residual volume
after each aspiration step on the
platform and
to do the volume which should be
left in the plate should be less than
five to ten microliters
so of course if it's zero microliters
that is very optimal
but in the normal under normal
conditions it's something between five
to ten micrometers
you can easily check this by stopping
the instrument
after the aspiration of the supernatant
taking out the plate
measuring it by a pipetting and then
thereby you can see
if the aspiration is efficient as you
want it to be
if you see that the residual volume is
higher than this amount
then you can start with the
troubleshooting so the first part would
be adjust the aspiration height by
surface teaching this is a very simplest
task which can be done by yourself on
the ep motion systems
if this does not help or only helps a
little bit then you can increase the
aspiration volume so
if you if you have aspirated before 600
microliters
you then aspirate 650 microliters
and of course of the third solution you
can prolong the drying step
to evaporate the remain residual ethanol
so these
three tips should always help you in
combination or
as a single a single task
to increase your or your got rid of your
qpcr inhibition or to increase your
performance
and one of the other most common
troubleshooting parts
especially with the magnetic beats is
the low purity
or low you have low purity due to
insufficient
resuspension of the magnetic beads
during magnetic bead-based processing
the resuspension
of the magnetic beads in the complete
wash buffer is really
the key to the for good performance
if the beats stay at the bottom during
mixing or shaking
then the performance will also be not
optimal
you can really you can easily see this
because the plates are more or less
transparent so you have a good
resuspension
when the plate comes off from the
thermal shaker and you can see the
the beads are distributed evenly in the
liquid
so that's a very good sign for a good
resuspension
we have a battery suspension if the
beads concentrate at the bottom and the
supernatant of the buffers
is still clear so then the shaking was
not enough
how to how to tackle then these these
symptoms is first of course you can
increase the shaking speed
be careful do not increase it too much
because otherwise
you risk spilling the buffers
by the shaking another point is you can
alternate the directions
so you can change between clockwise and
counter-clockwise like in an interval of
one minute or so
this helps to to loosen the bead pallet
the other part is what we always
recommend
is if you aspirate the supernatant after
you can see it in the picture so you
have the magnetic separation in the
middle you have the
removal of the supernatant and then you
add the washing buffer
and then you put it on the shaker you
can alter the order or the
um yeah the order of these steps
basically you aspirate the supernatant
and then you
place the empty plate on the shaker
shake it a little bit like 30 seconds
then move it back or and then add the
wash buffer
thereby because you shake the beads
without any buffer
you're already losing loosening up the
bead pellet and this helps then
with a complete resuspension and of
course if
nothing of these helps you can still
implement a pipette mixing step
i've as a closing remark i just want to
say usually
the mixing efficiency is very dependent
on the orbit of the shaker
so if you have a shaker with a good
orbit with a high
orbit then you don't run into into these
problems
okay and with these with this i wanted
to come to an end
and would like to hand over to my
colleague milan
thank you andreas for this very valuable
hands-on experience i think this is very
valuable information for the audience
because
uh it comes really from the application
r
d side and thank you also tim for
explaining uh the advantages of
automation
in general and of the ep motion
platforms
in particular um we are now at the end
of our presentation
we hope that this presentation was
useful
for you as our audience we will take
questions
uh from you we have time for a couple of
questions we
will not be able to answer all the
questions i think
and um yeah i just wanted already to say
thank you to
um to all of you for your attention
thank you gentlemen for your informative
presentation
let's jump right into that live q a
portion of our webinar
now we have so many questions that have
already come in but if you do have
additional questions you would like to
ask
just click on that ask a question box
located
at the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for
okay i do just want to dive in with this
first question it's come in
multiple times can we get a copy of
these slides
yeah i can answer that this is tim
speaking
so we will make a copy of those slides
available for you
um we might have to take out one
or another slide or have to adjust a
couple of things
um but we will make a pdf version
available for you
and they will be available via
lab routes as well if i'm not completely
mistaken chris you're right
yes that is correct labyrinths will send
out an email once we have that
downloadable pdf of these slides we'll
send you an email and you can come back
into the studio and download those
okay let's jump in and get a couple of
these questions
answered but i do want to let our
audience know that those questions were
unable to answer live today and any of
those that come in during the life
during the on-demand period they will be
addressed via the email address you
provided at the time of registration
okay let's start with this question and
milan let's go with you
on this question um how can you protect
rna
um yeah okay that's a good question
actually i think uh this came up because
i mentioned that that rna is much less
stable
than dna and that it is often a problem
in workflows involving rna that
degradation is happening so there are
two options to to protect rna
right from the start when you still have
your sample
so the one option would be and the best
option is to
purify your rna as soon as possible from
the sample so you don't even let the
sample
sit anywhere for a long time but you
just
directly add your lysis buffer and start
the purification process
usually all lysis buffers from rna kits
are designed in a way that
the rna is protected in the buffer once
the sample is lysed
and some kits also require the addition
of a reducing agent like better mccarthy
up ethanol or something like that
to further inhibit rna's activity
the other option would be to put your
sample into an rna stabilization reagent
there are several of those commercially
available also from macquarie nagle so
if you're interested in that you can
also go to our website and um just
search for nuclear protect uh it is
basically
a reagent and there are as i said
several of these in the market not only
from our company
uh a reagent that protects um that
infiltrates the sample and
thereby protects um the rna from
degradation so this would be
your options here
thank you mulan andreas let's come to
you for this next question
do we need any extra equipment for
magnetic bead-based
nucleic acid purification
so yeah so basically what you need is a
magnetic separator
which is also available from a diverse
set of
commercial distributors manufacturers
and then of course you need for the
automation
it is recommended to have a thermo
shaker shaking device
which is usually equipped on a bunch on
a couple of
platforms from appendoff on and you need
a gripping device
to move the plates from the magnetic
separator to the shaking device of
course you can also
do this manually then you only need a
magnetic separator and a pipette
thank you and andres let's stay with you
for this question as well
how can we affor how can we avoid
foaming
in nucleic acid purification using
silica
yeah so the deforming is a typical issue
which comes up with detergent
containing buffers during vacuum
processing
so what we have established is that in
our kit there's a certain wash buffer
with a high
concentration of ethanol but you also
can use basically
80 ethanol and we just perform an
overlay step
so basically before applying the vacuum
you just
add 150 micrometer of 80 ethanol
on top of the sample and then you apply
vacuum and thereby you get rid of all
the foaming
thank you now tim you mentioned
partial automation does this mean that
the system you have is
modular and can be adopted step by step
or would that be incrementally
yeah a very good question um so what i
mean with portal automation
here is that um only parts
of the entire workflow are automated so
you can distinguish basically between
the the automation of the
of the full workflow if we if we take
the journey from
the sample to the analysis
at the end which can be of different
sort
um if i refer to partial automation it's
more that
within this workflow there will always
be steps which are very
tedious which are very hard which are
very repetitive so if i think about
magnetic beats for example there will be
a lot of washing steps involved and
um it might be tricky to handle
especially plates
in that in that background manually so
it might
be useful to just automate
that one step that would then obviously
be not a full automation and you would
need an operator
working side by side with this
automation option
but it is an improvement over a full
manual process
and the advantage is that often only
very small systems or very
small tools are needed to get this part
of partial automation up and running
i hope that answered the question
thank you tim and we have time for one
final question and i'm going to go and
have you answer this question as well
how do we handle steps like
centrifugation during
automation when we choose to use silica
columns for na purification
yeah also a very good question is
actually a question
um that that we get a lot because if
you're doing
nucleic acid purification manually i
would guess
most of you are doing that with the
small spin columns
if you if you switch to automation
i have to say that most of the time you
cannot hold on to your spin columns but
you can usually hold on to the
the same chemistry and the same process
so
in this scenario the the spin columns
are replaced
by a plate format it's simply a 96 well
plate
with the the silica placed
in this plate so it's like 96 pin
columns connected
um and this is then not handled with a
centrifuge but
in most of the cases um with a vacuum
chamber
so instead of using
gravity to push your liquids
through those filter plates like with
the spin column
um you would place it on a vacuum
manifold where pressure
is used to to suck the the liquid
through those plates so it's the it's
the exact same procedure
um it's the usually also the
the same chemistry um it's just a
different
format of the consumables that you're
using and i think i have to add here at
that point
um that a very large automation solution
often has a or can have a built-in
centrifuge but
then we are talking really about a
usually
a very big system
thank you tim and thank you andreas and
milan for this informative
q a and your informative presentations
do you have any final comments for our
audience
uh yes i would just like to highlight
again that
in case you have any further questions
you can go to our website which are
displayed here
so either the macro inaudible website or
the ebnorf website and contact our
technical support at any time
with any problem you have related to the
topic of the
of the webinar we will try to answer
all of the questions that came in
throughout the webinar
and get back to you regarding these
questions
thank you again for your attendance
yeah and also from my side a big
big thank you for your attendance um
and also a big thank you for your
fantastic questions
there uh i think there were more than
100 questions we're pouring in here and
obviously we cannot answer all of those
questions live but as milan said
we will we will answer all of those
questions
via email please understand that due to
the sheer number of questions you asked
that this might
take a little while but we will
definitely get back to you with an
answer to your question
also from my side thank you for your
patience and thank you for your
attention and
of course have a nice weekend as well
thank you again to dr tim schalmart's dr
andreas von bull
and dr milan dearest for their time
today and for their important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor epidurf for underwriting
today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand
and nabruts will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
also be on the lookout for that extra
email coming to let you know when you
can download
a pdf of our powerpoint that's all for
now
we hope to see you again soon have a
great day
you